So as previously mentioned, Unreal has its own implementation of the C++ 11, I think, Smart Pointer Library.
It's worth just going into a little bit.
So anytime you have non-new objects that you want to have the memory managed for you in some way,
Smart Pointers are definitely something to consider.
You're probably already familiar with Smart Pointers for more C++ if that's something you've used before,
but just to kind of briefly go through them.
We have T-Shared Pointer, which is essentially a reference counted pointer.
So as this reference is copied around and passed around,
we keep track of how many things have access to that pointer.
As that number of references hits zero, then that memory is freed.
So we don't have to worry, it's kind of shared ownership of this pointer.
T-Unique Pointer is kind of the opposite of that, where we say one thing manages this memory,
so as and when this thing stops referencing it, we're going to free that memory, just automatically.
And T-Weak Pointer is when we say this pointer doesn't manage that memory at all.
It is conscious that that memory might get cleaned up underneath it.
It's really helpful for things like lambdas that might get executed,
and you're aware that execution may occur after the objects it's referencing are already deleted for other reasons.
So a Weak Pointer is a way you can say,
I'm not sure if this object still exists, but if it does, I want to perform some functions on it or something like that.
So those are the kind of standard C++ smart pointer library types that you would be aware of.
And then we also have two additional ones.
We have T-Shared Ref, which is the relationship from pointer to ref,
where a ref is essentially a promise that this can never be null.
The same thing applies for a T-Shared Ref, it's just in the shared pointer library.
And last of all, we have T-Weak Object Pointer.
Whereas the rest of these are intended for non-U-Object types,
T-Weak Object Pointer provides the same functionality as T-Weak Pointer,
but specifically for U-Object types.
So that same concept, again, the first thing I think of is lambdas.
Whenever you're passing a reference to a U-Object,
that you're aware that U-Object might be gone by the time that lambda executes,
T-Weak Object Pointer is a thing to consider using.
So the benefits of smart pointers, largely the same as C++ smart pointer benefits.
So if you're not aware of them, it helps prevent memory leaks.
That's a really, really common one. That's why they were introduced in the first place.
Unlike U-Objects, where it's highly recommended, you don't access them off the game thread.
The smart pointer library, particularly shared pointers, can be thread-safe.
It's worth a highlight that there are two options when you create a shared pointer.
It can be a thread-safe shared pointer, or it can be non-thread-safe.
The thread-safe pointer has its reference counting done by an atomic operation,
which essentially is an operation that occurs between threads.
So there's no way that two threads can end up in a race condition
for how many things are referencing this object.
That's beneficial for thread safety, but it does come at a certain performance cost,
so it's just worth bearing that in mind.
And then the last thing is obviously the runtime safety of T-SharedRef,
which is very, very useful.
The other thing to point out is obviously this is an implementation
of the C++ standard smart pointer library,
but the reason we would recommend using Unreal's implementation of these things
is it's platform agnostic.
So when it comes to actually something that implements or makes use of this shared pointer library,
it's worth highlighting that if it's from a non-reflected type,
we need to inherit from the T-SharedThis class.
So this is what an example implementation of that would look like.
We have some class, then we inherit from T-SharedThis,
and this is a generic implementation,
so we need to provide the class that we're implementing
as the argument there for the generic function.
And what this does is it gives us access to a suite of functions.
We have makeShared and makeSharable,
which are basically two ways of creating a shared pointer,
a shared reference for this type.
makeShared is encouraged to be used over makeSharable
because it's slightly more performant.
And then asShared and sharedThis basically just give us a sharedRef to that type,
but it's expecting that that type is already created.
And then these are all about getting access to a sharedRef,
and once we have that sharedRef,
we can easily dereference that into a T-Shared pointer to then pass around
if you don't want that runtime null checking safety.